there are always things that you can do
to speed up your results and to maximize
fat burning
pretty much every week on my live show
i'll have someone that is struggling
with weight loss or they're plateauing
and so
this video will go through every single
point that comes up when you're trying
to lose weight and you're unsuccessful
and you may just need one of these
points to crack the case and lose weight
like you want to now that being said
what i'm going to show you is a bit
extreme but some people need to
go to this level
to see the results that they need if our
goal is to get you into fat burning and
get your body to
run on as much fat calories as we can
there's a great measurement of ketones
to be able to see that
through your blood okay you can measure
ketones get a little ketone device and
check not the urine but the blood
so it goes on the scale right here and
you'll probably
never really see above three unless you
do several other things which i'm going
to explain
you'll usually stay between one two and
maybe three if you do
keto and intermittent fasting okay but
when you add more exercise more hardcore
exercise it'll go a little bit deeper
the numbers going up are deeper ketosis
right and then if we add prolonged
fasting okay we can see higher and
higher numbers depending on how many
days that you fast for
now sometimes people are concerned about
um ketoacidosis if it gets too high like
9.5 to 10 right which you're getting the
ketoacidosis
this condition
only happens if you are a type 1
diabetic and you have no more insulin
and you're not regulating your blood
sugars or you forget to take your
insulin whatever
so if you're producing insulin you're
never gonna get to this level okay
so i just wanted to show you this what
what i'm gonna show you is how to
go as high as you can right up through
here
doing other things okay including
exercise and prolonged fasting and what
you're going to see in the majority of
this video is things you're not going to
do okay versus doing certain things okay
you're going to be avoiding things
that's going to create the biggest
change okay
so number one dropping your carbs close
to zero so that means not consuming any
berries or nuts unless you consume
academia nuts
no yogurt there's sugar in yogurt
no kefir
no carrots beets corn squash peas or
tomatoes you can do leafy greens but i
wouldn't do these okay
the closer you can get your carbs to
zero
the more ketones we're going to generate
number two
no extra fat okay with the meal so that
means no mct oil why because
your body is going to
use this
before it uses your own fat reserve
no bulletproof coffee okay which is
basically mct oil and butter in your
coffee no keto bombs right after these
little desserts right after your meal
just don't eat those okay
and especially if they're
if you buy them because they they stick
all these different ingredients in them
but we don't want to add more fat uh
than necessary you only want to consume
the fat that comes with the protein and
i wouldn't add any anything in your
coffee either just drink black coffee so
no half and half or no cream at this
stage i'm just going through all the
things that potentially could slow you
down a little bit okay and if you add
all these things together
you're pretty much guaranteed success
okay three
no sugar alcohols this is the
alternative sweeteners that a lot of
people use on keto like no xylitol
erythritol not that there's sugar in
them but they can really alter your
digestive system
and that can create bloating and
additional problems this is why we're
going to also recommend no almond flour
so many people have an issue with almond
flour okay
they get bloating
and also no keto packaged foods
nowadays they're slipping in all these
synthetic fibers these new called
functional fibers the soluble corn fiber
the tapioca fiber and additional hidden
maltodextrin that they don't even put on
the label so we just want to avoid that
so that way
it's not going to be a barrier all right
number four
when you go to a restaurant it's
crapshoot there's so much seed oils that
they fry food in that they put into the
food
at restaurants especially fast food
restaurants but other restaurants as
well
when i go out to a restaurant i really
have to read that menu and i'm really
asking the waitress or the waiter very
specific questions about these
ingredients because my body is very
sensitive i can pick up if there's any
hidden sugar in the food or chemicals
and i'll walk away from that restaurant
not feeling quite right
because i'll know that there's something
in there that disagreed with my body so
at this stage if you really want to see
some
great results i would just
not go to any restaurants cook your own
food so you can control it okay
now only one cup of coffee not more than
that because we don't want to add more
caffeine that can inhibit your sleep
it also adds more strain in the liver
because the liver has to work hard at
detoxifying the caffeine
all right number six apple cider vinegar
like one tablespoon in a glass of water
before your meal why because apple cider
vinegar
is really good at helping
your blood sugars okay at improving this
insulin resistance
problem
also the apple cider vinegar will help
your stomach be a little more acidic so
you'll get better digestion
all right let's go to the next
section here all right
seven
no more than eight ounces of protein per
meal why because if you have too much
protein that can spike insulin so
typically you want to go from i don't
know three to six ounces
to no more than eight ounces of protein
per meal
but because we're doing omad one meal a
day monday through friday
you want to eat a little more protein so
seven eight ounces would be a good
amount
the type of protein does matter you want
protein with the fat that normally comes
with it you don't want to do any lean
protein but you want fatty protein like
hamburger
like you can do fatty steak
salmon
fish seafood eggs
and you can also do some cheese if it's
quality like an organic european cheese
from grass-fed cows
from raw milk cheese that would be the
best cheese is a good source of protein
without the carbs as compared to other
dairy like just regular milk or kefir
or yogurt i also recommend no protein
powders why because there's all sorts of
stuff in there and also it's too lean
okay the leaner you go with the protein
the higher you spike insulin
all right i also recommend not consuming
any pre-made shakes okay they have a lot
of weight loss shakes they have a lot of
meal substitutes and a shake
avoid those there are certain
ingredients that you don't want to put
in your body all right next point would
be
number eight one meal a day monday
through friday okay
and you don't have to restrict your
calories okay consume enough food make
sure it's nutrient dense and then the
weekends okay saturday and sunday do a
48-hour
fast now you might at first think that's
extreme
but the amount of health that's going to
be generated in your body on all
different levels is going to be
incredible not to mention your
metabolism it's going to improve and you
can also bust through that set point
that that weight level that you just
can't seem to get past i think this is a
really good pattern for not just weight
loss but health in general and also as
an anti-cancer thing make sure you take
your electrolytes b vitamins
and sea salt anytime you do fasting okay
number nine
very important
i did another video on how significant
stress is
with
with your weight with your metabolism
with increasing cortisol you need to do
what's called a stress detox okay
and the biggest source of stress is
other people so you want to avoid any
and all people who stress you out
there's really two
groups of people people that are
bringing you up and people that are
bringing you down
anyone that brings you down or stresses
you out you want to just put them on
pause for a while and your stress level
is going to go down
and you also want to stop watching the
news why because it's mostly bad news
there's not a lot of good news
and also try to limit as much as you can
so if you don't watch the news don't
hang out with these people you're not
going to have a lot of bad news and that
is going to make a huge shift
in your sanity
your stress level and cortisol
you want to keep super busy okay why
so you don't have time
to think too much right and start
worrying and being stressed out so many
people if they have idle time
get to thinking and start to stress
themselves out and too much thinking
especially if it's like analyzing
different problems constantly can
definitely increase your cortisol level
so you just want to stay really busy so
you can keep your mind off these
problems for a period of time as well as
preventing
boredom right because the worst thing
you can do is sit around while there's
food in the kitchen and not be busy okay
so that's that one and then physical
work or exercise
two to three times a week for one hour i
would recommend doing more physical work
if you can because that's very
therapeutic why because apparently this
also handles the mental stress at the
same time more than actual exercise does
now the type of exercise you want to do
is something like significant something
that
you know you're going to get sore the
next day you really want to work your
full body
high intensity interval training would
be the best not just like
five minutes you really want to work out
till you get tired
and you might not be able to do that
without the help of a personal trainer
so you might want to think about that
get as much sun as you can without
burning yourself because this is very
therapeutic
to reduce cortisol real quick i had a
patient once who had this huge belly and
every time he went down to florida for a
vacation he'd come back
his stomach was completely flat and he
wouldn't change his diet but he's out in
the sun and the fresh air and the sun
and the lower stress
just reduced his cortisol also be around
nature is much as possible
number 10
fermented veggies like one cup like
either sauerkraut or kimchi a day is
really going to help your gut
and your sleeping which i'm going to
mention
or if you can't do that just take a
probiotic before bed it's going to help
your sleep and it's going to help you
lose more weight all right number 11
support the beta cell what's the beta
cell that's the cell the pancreas that's
regulating and producing insulin so you
want to make sure you have enough
potassium foods magnesium foods those
are the big salads vitamin d
you can also get these as a supplement
from electrolytes but vitamin d is very
very important with your pancreas and
helping you lower insulin and so is b1
in the form of nutritional yeast
these four are really good to help
insulin resistance and to help the
pancreas
and last but not least number 12 sleep
if possible
i would recommend going to bed at 9 30.
that might sound pretty drastic but
that's the time i go to bed and
you get this cycle down where you know
you go to bed and try to get as much
sleep as you can you might wake up in
the middle of night but just try to get
back to sleep and try to sleep as long
as possible okay get at least eight
hours i did a recent video on sleep
that's very very important
that will help you regulate the amount
of light that you're exposed to in fact
i think that's the next one you should
watch check it out i put it up right
here
you